18h à istanbul c'est l'heure du bulletin
nouvelles de hawke tv une télévision
privée et suivi par des millions turc
c'est aussi une des rares télévision
encore indépendante du pouvoir en
turquie mais sa jeune équipe en paient
parfois le prix
comment la turquie candidate à l'union
européenne est membre du g20 et de
l'otan en est arrivé là depuis 20 ans et
les le pays d'un seul homme redjep
tayyip erdogan démocrates et
conservateurs musulmans il prend le
pouvoir en 2003 au sortir d'une grave
crise économique
la turquie devient alors un modèle de
développement avec une croissance
moyenne de 7 % par année les dix ont dix
premières années
de son pouvoir en tant que premier
ministre à la tête de la turquie sont
des années de prospérité croissante pour
l'économie de la turquie au sens large
mais pour les citoyens turcs en
particulier qui voient leur pouvoir
d'achat augmenter de façon exponentielle
les investissements directs étrangers
affluent et en turquie un an de loire
vient de publier un livre sur here
douanes correspondante radio à istanbul
depuis 12 ans elle nous parle des
ambitions de celui qui est devenu au fil
des réformes un président tout puissant
qui a la main sur la justice le
parlement et même la banque centrale red
hat est hyper donne il n'a fait que de
la politique de toute sa vie qui sans
doute croit en une mission
parmi ses réalisations la transformation
complète du réseau de la santé devenue
très efficace il a fait construire des
dizaines de grands hôpitaux comme celui
ci à istanbul
travaux
députés pour la cape et le parti fondé
par ailleurs doan et au pouvoir depuis
2002 hâtive chat un clic est un proche
du président
une affirmation que de nombreux turcs
devront peut-être pas vu l'évolution
récente du pays ce qu'on a vu pendant la
paire d année 2010 c'est un job day
personnes qui de plus en plus se sent
menacée avec plusieurs tournants
en 2013 les choses se gâtent après une
manifestation écologique pour sauver le
pack guézy d'istanbul que le
gouvernement veut raser
le mouvement se transforme en
manifestation de colère contraire
douanes et embrasse tout le pays des
milliers de personnes sont blessées par
la police la liberté d'expression en
prend un coup plus ils accumulaient des
pouvoirs dans sa personne il a
glissé le régime politique dell
l'autoritarisme ibrahim k boucle ou et
députés pour le principal parti
d'opposition il se souvient de l'autre
événement majeur qui a renforcé la
méfiance du président r doan
dans la nuit du 15 juillet 2016 une
faction de l'armée sur tente un coup
d'état mais la tentative échoue l'état
d'urgence est décrété commence alors une
purge sans précédent plus de cent mille
fonctionnaires sont congédiés et des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
arrêtées des garanties
constitutionnelles concernant le
libertaire peuvent être bafoués
quotidiennement ce qui au départ était
présenté comme une action pour
débarrassé l'état de ces putchistes
s'élargit très tôt en une traque des
opposants
le président affiche aussi plus que
jamais son islamisme et demos qui
apparaissent un peu partout au pays
quant à l'économie turque elle est en
proie à une inflation de 54% et le
pouvoir d'achat de la population est en
chute libre les prochaines élections
sont prévues en 2023 et verront deux
turquie s'affronter celle de caching
pêcheurs ou agrandir douanes il a ses
affiches partout on a l'impression d'y
être déjà en campagne électorale le
président a tout fait pour le pays il a
créé des emplois
je l'aimais beaucoup je suis fier du
réseau de la santé de tous ces ponts et
serrault qu'il a bâtie il a fait entrer
la turquie dans l'ère moderne
mais il ya aussi la turquie de tous ceux
qui rêvent d'un pays différent la
démocratie turque est ce que ça existe
une circo on recule moi j'ai soixante
dix huit ans j'ai vraiment vécu beaucoup
de choses en turquie des périodes très
difficiles mais jamais aussi difficile
que maintenant
de représailles le père des gays au goût
ne lui avait suggéré de ne pas nous
parler
aux prochaines élections 7 millions de
jeunes voteront pour la première fois en
turquie soit environ 11 % de tous les
électeurs l'action d'aller dans une urne
et de porter un candidat ou un parti et
un peu en quelque sorte le dernier
rempart de la démocratie en turquie
oui si
ivan ljubici promet quoi qu'il arrive de
continuer à faire son métier tout en
rêvant à plus de liberté pour lui et ses
collègues